can you paint a map of
water chimps gorillas and humans like
how we're related and what you find
fascinating about each
in africa
straddling the equator
there is a strip of rainforest
that
relies on the combination of
high temperatures and rainfall that you
get around the equator
that rainforest goes into about
22 countries
and throughout those countries
you have chimpanzees although they've
gone extinct in two of them
i
in a
just a fraction of them but was it
five countries uh you've got
gorillas
where there are mountains
and in one country on the left bank of
the great congo river you have bonobos
so in the african forest you've got
these three african apes the only
african apes
all of which
are
very similar in
much of their
way of life
they walk on their knuckles
through the forest looking for fruit
trees
and eating
herbs when they can't find fruits
gorillas
represent the oldest chain
so about
10 million years ago maybe as recently
as eight million years ago
the ancestor gorillas broke off from the
ancestor leading to chimps and bonobos
and humans
so they've probably remained very
similar now to what
very similar to what they were then they
were probably
the largest apes
living in mountain areas and
spending more time
eating just
herbs stems
not so vitally dependent on fruit
and
living in um
if there was like the present
uh groups up to about 50 stable groups
with uh one alpha male who was in charge
uh
gorillas are
wonderfully
slow
uh and inquisitive compared to chimps
and bonobos yeah
and i had the
privilege of
spending uh a week or two with
gorillas um
at diane fosse's camp when before she
was murdered
and
i i i went out
with uh two women
kelly and bob
to a particular group
and
there was a young female in the group
called simba
and simba approached us
and stared at the two women and then she
came towards me
and uh she
very deliberately reached out her
knuckles and touched me on the forehead
she was watched in doing this
by a young male who was quite keen on
her
and he was called digit
and about five minutes later
digit
stood in front of us on the path
and kelly was in front of me
and then there was bob and then there
was me
and he came charging down the path and
he sidestepped around kelly and he
sidestepped around barb
and me
he just knocked with his arm and sent me
flying about five yards into the bushes
and i loved the way that
that was a very deliberate response and
i loved the way that simba had been so
interested in me and and held my eye
chimps and broke never hold your eye but
gorillas really look as though they're
trying to sort of figure out what are
you thinking about
that was
a species that just goes back for uh
something like 10 million years in that
situation
was there a game being played
um
well i mean i i felt that digit was
telling me i don't want you messing with
with simba or was simba
using you
oh i see
well that's a fun idea uh i don't see
why she should be using me but you mean
testing how yeah strongly the affection
prefered to intervene too yeah exactly
oh that's
that's comes straight out of a sort of
adolescent to high school playbook all
right well that's that's no there's
nothing wrong with it brother for that
um yeah
i don't know i never thought of that and
you never know
so so yeah so okay so this is an ancient
branch of the evolutionary tree and this
gorilla that led to gorillas gorillas um
so then the next thing that happened on
the evolutionary tree was uh six or
seven million years ago when
uh
you have the line
uh between chimps and bonobos on the one
hand and humans on the other splitting
and basically what happened is that
at that point a chimp-like ancestor
leaves the forest
gets isolated in an area outside the
forest and adapts and that becomes the
australopithecines and meanwhile the
chimpanzees
uh
and bonobo ancestor continues in the
forest
and
later what happens is that one branch of
that crosses the congo river and becomes
the bonobos
that was only about two million years
ago maybe one million years ago
now the chimps that remained in the
forest throughout this time and occupied
all the countries across uh from east
west to east africa now
again we assume that they're pretty
similar to the ones that live nowadays
uh whether some variation from from west
to east
and these are animals that live in um
social communities of uh between say 20
and uh and 200. they have a lot of them
in one group but they never come
together in a single unit
these are they share an area at a
community territory
and that area is defended by males and
within females uh wander and bring up
their young independently
and
the females are very scared about
the possibility that males will be mean
to their infants and in order to
avoid them doing that they do their best
to mate with every single male in the
group multiple times as if to give a
memory in that mail of yeah yeah i
remembered you so i'm not going to be
mean to your baby
so what's wonderful about chimps well
you know as we've spoken about them yeah
they are creative and um
and so amazingly human-like
but i love the the sort of you know the
quiet moments and and here's one
um
i've got uh
uh two chimps who are uh grooming each
other on a day when they are utterly
exhausted
they've walked um
11 kilometers the day before up and down
hills
and
on this particular day all they do is
they get to one tree
and they eat from that tree and other
than that they only walk about a hundred
yards and they go back to sleep in the
nest in which they woke up
so they're utterly exhausted um
and they're just eating non-stop because
they're trying to recover uh their
energy
and this is uh hugh and charlie and we
think they were probably brothers that
we never actually
got the genetic evidence to to prove it
well um
i never remember now who it is but let's
say that um they both come down from the
tree
and um
they're both
carrying branches of the food they're
eating actually seeds from these
branches
they're both engaged
even in the midday sun when they want to
come down and
unshade themselves for a bit on the
ground
um they're still eating but then charlie
finishes his branch
and
he starts grooming hugh
and uh
hugh
continues eating from his branch
charlie
eventually gets bored of this after a
few minutes
and he reaches out
and he
lifts the branch from which hugh is
still taking seeds
and
puts it over his head and puts it behind
his back as far as possible away from
hugh
hugh doesn't do anything
he just finishes his mouthful and then
he turns to charlie and grooms him so
this very polite way of saying will you
groom me please has worked
then
hugh
grooms around charlie's back
and around our to the right side and
then down his arm to what point where he
can reach
the branch again
and then he picks up the branch and
continues
nonchalantly right yeah so in other
words you know they are very sort of
simple little strategy yeah but it just
shows the the courtesy with which they
can uh treat each other
and you know the days i love with jim so
when you see that sort of thing or when
you see
mothers just lying in a
sunlit patch in the forest with babies
bouncing on top of them um just uh
having a wonderful peaceful time and
that's you know that's what most of
their lives are like
so chimpanzees are the
species that kind of unites the rest of
the apes because a gorilla is in many
ways a just a big version of a
chimpanzee if you can sort of engineer a
chimpanzee in your mind to be bigger it
basically turns into a gorilla
and then bonobos
on the left bank of the congo river
are a
like a domesticated form of
of chimpanzee but obviously humans
didn't domesticate them so they're
self-domesticated they are less
aggressive and they show all the marks
of domestication that domesticated
animals do in compared to wild animals
in their bones
so they have reduced differences between
males and females in which the males are
more like females they have smaller
brains they have
shorter
faces smaller teeth and smaller bodies
all the things that domesticate animals
show and and bonobos live in this
environment in a strikingly peaceful way
compared to the chimpanzees there's no
indication that they will have these
aggressive kills
and enough data now to show that there's
a statistical difference in the
frequency of which it would happen and
bonobos are famously uh erotic
the females have
enlarged sexual
parts
which swell to particularly
large size compared to the
female chimpanzees
and the females have a lot of
interactions with each other in which
they excitedly rub their clitorises
together and um and appear to have
orgasms
and wow these occur in the context of
um
some kind of social tension
and they sometimes happen before it
sounds happen after the social tension
and they seem to be devices
these interactions for um ensuring that
everyone's friends and uh reducing the
chances that they're actually going to
get into a fight just a kind of uh
conflict resolution through uh
through sex or some kind of pleasurable
sexual experience well it's often
characterized as make love not war
that's right make love not war
you